yeah so why why do you think that has
happened what's the motive behind it
why harvard discriminates against asian
americans
because
harvard uh
they really want a racially specifically
a racially diverse class so they see
asians as overrepresented
right because if harvard did not
discriminate against asian americans
asians would make up about 43 percent of
harvard's student body based on merit
alone based on grades test scores
so what they do is that they
artificially lower that to about half
asian americans only to less than half
asian americans make about 20
of harvard's student body
because harvard wants to admit more
people of diverse races and they think
it makes them more virtuous
okay so so let's go through this so 43
would be the student body asians if
it was basic based on merits but it's
not it's currently 20
and if we look at the uh based on
national population i think asians make
up 5.9 percent yeah america give or take
blacks are 13.4 hispanics are about 18
and a half
then you got the whites who are the
non-hispanic whites are a little over 60
and you got
a small percentage of middle easterns
and others like myself that make up the
rest of the percentage right
so why is it why is it help me
understand this part
why is it that the population is only
5.9
asian
yet based on the criteria's 43
would be in harvard that's 5.9 to 43 why
is that what are the asian families
doing differently than the rest of us
they are teaching
values that beget a good educational
excellence so asian americans study
twice as many hours as the average
american right they they study about 15
hours a week the average american
studies about seven
um asian americans
tend to prioritize
academic excellence because they have to
because you come to this country and you
don't have generational wealth you don't
have privilege you don't have social
connections how are you going to move up
in society how are you going to provide
a better future for your for your kids
well it has to be through education
because that's the great lever forward
in asian american culture they really
prioritize
the valuing of of education especially
chinese and chinese centered
cultures
it's it's pretty much baked into
you know the the confucian system in
some way the the ancient old tradition
um
and uh and as a result you know and the
other thing that asians do is that they
have better two-parent family structures
that allow them to provide a conducive
environment for academic excellence
because you can have a
you know
you don't your parent can pay more
attention to the child and that's very
much valued in the culture so that's
what begets the academic excellence part
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you